on the road to Israel's parliament a
human chain
thousands of demonstrators forming a
wall of opposition to prime minister
Benjamin netanyahu's controversial plans
to change Israel's judiciary
outside the knesset despite the
scorching heat protesters gathered
stepped up security and additional
barricades only showcasing the
heightened sense of anxiety in a country
more polarized than ever before I came
here today because I believe that our
democracy is in danger
it's in danger not just because of the
specific law they're trying to pass now
but because of the entire approach of
the government
the bill is just one part of a larger
package of proposals by Netanyahu and
his far-right Coalition the critics say
would significantly limit the power of
the Courts for his part Netanyahu says
the plan would strengthen Israeli
democracy
is expected to take place on Monday if
it is enacted into law it would mean
that among other things the Supreme
Court would no longer have the power to
overrule government or ministerial
decisions which it deems to be
unreasonable
with debate going on in the knesset
protester amnon lavav tells us the plans
underway by the most right-wing
government in Israel's history are
endangering the country they're
dismantling all the barriers and their
all the restrictions and all the checks
and balances so that takes us in the
direction of the dictatorship which we
do not accept
others worry the Prime Minister has put
Israel on a path toward autocracy Bibi
Netanyahu is already a dictator and
Israel should be a democracy this is
what we are this is in our DNA
don't want to be a dictator
a resounding and defiant message from a
protest movement that doesn't look to be
weaning anytime soon
West Jerusalem
U.S President Joe Biden has issued a
statement ahead of Monday's vote urging
Benjamin Netanyahu to Halt the
legislation our White House
correspondent Kimberly halcott has more
from Washington D.C
this is significant the reason that this
is happening in terms of this statement
by Joe Biden is because the feeling is
by the White House is that Benjamin
Netanyahu is simply not listening to the
urgings of the White House and a long
time Ally so what we have is really an
11th Hour attempt by President Biden to
convince the Israeli Prime Minister to
Halt the legislation aimed at
overhauling the Israeli Judiciary and so
what the president has done is issued a
statement to multiple news outlets
including Al Jazeera really urging the
prime minister to change his mind what
the statement says is from the
perspective of Israel's friends in the
United States it looks like the current
judicial reform proposal is becoming
more divisive not less given the range
of threats and challenges confronting
Israel right now it doesn't make sense
for Israeli leaders to rush this the
focus should be on pulling people
together and finding consensus and of
course we've seen people protesting
certainly underscoring that people are
not being pulled together in Israel
right now over this legislation and
these proposed reforms package but this
isn't the only friction point that
exists right now between Israel and the
United States we know that the White
House is Gravely concerned about the
expansion of Jewish settlements in the
occupied West Bank so much so that when
is the Israeli Prime Minister was
re-elected into office last December the
White House really held back on issuing
an invitation for Benjamin Netanyahu to
come to the White House something that
was only recently extended in terms of a
meeting with President Biden as of last
week and it's still not clear if that
will be at the White House or perhaps on
the sidelines of the U.N general
assembly in the fall but what is very
clear is that there's a lot of
frustration in the part of President Joe
Biden with his counterpart so much so
that he recently described Benjamin
netanyahu's far-right Coalition is one
of the most extremist since the 1970s
well let's take a closer look at what
the proposed judicial changes are the
full package proposed by Israel's
government will reduce Court's Powers it
proposes giving the Israeli Parliament
the ability to override Supreme Court
decisions with a simple majority of 61
votes it would allow politicians to
choose which judges to appoint at the
moment judges are selected by an
independent panel the changes would also
remove the Supreme Court's ability to
review the legality of what's known as
Israel's basic laws which function as
its Constitution
president Isaac Herzog has vocally
opposed the proposal saying it's pushing
Israel to the verge of legal and social
collapse
is a political analyst and former
spokeswoman for the Palestinian
Authority she says the Israeli state has
never faced a crisis like this before
I think what's happening is very
interesting
um you know it right now the dynamic
between the ultra right
um in Israel and the Army
um you know is coming to a head and this
is a very militarized Society there is a
mandatory military service everybody
reports to duty so to speak and they
stay on in the reserves and to see such
an overwhelming uh opposition from the
Army is very significant and it is
unprecedented and that's why I think
we've seen and and heard from senior
Israeli officials in the opposition
um and and former diplomats and former
generals warning that Israel is at a
Breaking Point and again we're talking
about the Jewish Israeli component of
Israel that is facing a crisis it has
never faced before being this polarized
having the right wing the religious
right-wing uh so much in power there is
a self-image I think that is Israelis
have enjoyed about themselves so far
which is that they are a liberal
democracy that they are progressive that
they you know um are a beacon of light
if you will in the region and all of
that in many ways is coming you know uh
crashing down
um in the face of a right-wing
government that wants to impose strict
term or religious laws on on Jewish
Israelis that wants to have more control
over appointments that wants to Shield
itself from accountability so all of
those really opposed the the self-image
that Israel has created for itself and
that Israelis have been comfortable with
while isolating themselves from the fact
that they are occupying another country
and subjecting another people to foreign
military rule